sleeping around different for men and
for women yes or no yeah men don't have
to face the consequences yeah I think
the same I think yeah when when women do
it it's not really acceptable but when
guys do it it's fine I don't know oh for
sure definitely it depends less fun
though it's not less fun it's just that
women face how to face the consequences
men like just get branded as like
Legends and women judge other women as
well for sleeping around I think but as
you get older yeah I think people care
less nowadays if girls sleep around more
in school that's when it's like some
dudes especially with like the whole
Andrew Tate thing some dudes actually
care about body count and [ __ ] that's so
important do you think body count
matters [ __ ] no in fact the higher the
better you actually know what you're
doing in bed so I have a question would
you guys say your body count no so if it
doesn't matter like why don't people
just say it
but it's just it's just interesting
because we'll say it doesn't matter but
then it's like if it doesn't matter why
doesn't everyone just say it very
intellectual thoughts because honestly
like for a guy for a guy I think I think
like like personally like I wish I was a
virgin I wish I waited until marriage I
think one is too many I wish I did yeah
I really I like I wish I was a virgin
yeah really have a relationship and need
to know that the person that you're
going to marry is yeah exactly
sexual chemistry sexual chemistry is so
important I feel like if you wait you
won't know like okay I think it's
different like once you've had sex most
women are allowed to have fun and women
can't until marriage I mean I think it's
it's actually if you look at the stats
it's better if they're both virgins like
the longest marriages are of both people
compare it to you I guess if it's your
first time you everything feels great
I don't know
no she doesn't know do you know what I
mean those but it's it's just
interesting because like when I ask
people they say it doesn't matter but
then no one ever wants guys here eat too
they don't want to say it either yeah
my guy friends are like I'd rather not
tell you my body count just
like it's just personal information
isn't it what do you so the average age
of first marriage in the UK is 31. what
do you think the average body count is
for a 31 year old woman 40 40
50 maybe 20. oh my God
20 23. we went hot do you know what's
interesting though I asked guys how many
bodies there's too many bodies they all
say 10 but but that's what I'm saying
but everyone I ask what's the average
body count of first marriage it's above
10 so it's like it seems like someone's
capping yeah they're not being realistic
is definitely for females there's a lot
more body count than males I think I
think you're you're right one out of
three months are either virgins or they
haven't had sex in the past year so
that's that's the thing like the reason
girls say men are trash and like you
guys have this perception that men are
sleeping around like not you but like
you're like oh okay in general but it's
because like we're all sleeping with the
same guys because it's only five percent
of men get matches really on Tinder
if you hook up with a guy off an online
like you're one of like sleeping around
is it different for men and for women
yeah why because there's like a
stereotype in it that obviously women
should be not sleeping around or
mentioned but I mean women should
because at the end of the day if you're
single why not or is it the same should
be the same what do you think I think it
used to be but not anymore would you be
cool with the girl that slept with 500
men that's her own business you can do
what she wants no I'm saying would you
would you marry her I mean if she's good
to me I probably wouldn't but I don't
think I wouldn't expect loads of girls
to marry me if I did do you feel like
it's the same in society it's treated
equally no not through everyone yeah do
you think body count matters no what's
your body count three all right yeah
that's funny that's what we said people
would say tonight before we came out I
haven't got a high body count but it
shouldn't matter but you know what I
mean it's just interesting because
everyone says it doesn't matter but a
lot of times people don't want to say it
[Music]
is sleeping around different for men and
for women yes or no is sleep is sleeping
around different for men and for why
because guys when they can get away with
anything and us girls get labeled I mean
it can be the same you know we are men
so it can't be the same it can't be the
same cannot it cannot why because men
have the intensity we feel the intensity
of them of the movement of the the music
deep down what do you think what do you
think for me it's the same sleeping
around different for men and for women
yeah
yeah hi because oh [ __ ] Bro men are
supposed to stay loyal but it's just
when we when we go around it doesn't
mean anything when girls do it it does
mean something is that do you think
that's fair it's not fair at all but go
live our lives do you think body count
matters if you're dating a guy do you
care what his body counts I don't
[ __ ] camera I ask a question will you
will you tell him if he asks you I'll
lie
how many how many bodies there's too
many bodies for you to wife a girl
there's no numbers to it I don't think
no number so 100. cool I'm cool with 100
yeah
you called the hundred
bodies to go in the snow yeah it's about
100 we're cool 100 we're cool what's
your body count no
oh no
the question of the day is is sleeping
around different for men and for women
yeah definitely yeah yeah men have one
functionality if we simplify things
that's to impregnate women women have
one functionality if we simplify things
that's to give birth nine months okay
how many girls can get pregnant in nine
months oh just just by one yeah yeah why
because if you're a woman and you're
sleeping around you probably get BV you
probably get other STIs while amen is
not so
so you say body count matters
and say yes but we don't care
um that's a personal preference for you
for me that's a personal preference but
each to their own and that's that's my
take on it so what's your body count
why
why am I carrying though like what
benefit is that well and the reason I
ask is because people often will say it
doesn't matter and so if I say if it
doesn't matter what's your body count
well I've just lost count like why would
I count yeah so you you're right so you
stand by it like if you knew you'd
probably tell me but a lot of people
wouldn't yeah my body count is one so
hey
is that true her body counts one yeah
I see I see what you did there how many
bodies is too many bodies for you to
wife a girl my body car is one no my
body got zero actually I'm a liar that's
my body has zero so my girl cannot be
less than zero oh okay realistically
I've met a lot of virgins to people that
claim they're virgin I'm a virgin claim
I don't like that word I don't like that
you are virgins how old are you guess my
age 28 25 no no you're spotting you turn
it on your spot on your spot and you're
like I'm a 28 year old virgin co-signer
you you've what why have you waited this
because I have Prestige and self-respect
it's not any girl that can you know what
I mean okay okay so he's a virgin you're
co-signing this
we're all a virgin out here like a lot
that can be opened by any key yes it's a
worthless look imagine your lucky door
with that can you use it
we are a virgin out here I mean we have
to wait for the right woman on the right
time why would you guys rate yourselves
one to ten ten [ __ ] 10 baby
everybody's at 10. that's the thing like
everyone is at 10 everyone is unique
everyone is special don't you think if
it's if you're saying you're a 10
doesn't that mean you're perfect
no no Tim means that I'm unique there's
no one else like me in the world and
there's nobody like her there's nobody
like you there's nobody like him in the
world very unique really I think there's
a million people like me I think I'm not
UDS
we can be similar but we are not the
same I think the biggest lie we tell
ourselves is that we're special I don't
think that most people are special yeah
we are special there's like a million
people like do like people come and go
you know what I mean no but everyone
come and go but like there's nobody like
you everyone is special everyone is
unique everyone have something different
to someone else where are you guys from
Tenerife where Tenerife Canary Islands
oh okay okay whales okay I was like I
didn't the Accents in London are always
so I speak in Spanish do you have any
socials Instagram you want to play yes
at me so
like
divinity with Kirsty come learn to twerk
of me
I don't know if you heard the brands but
yeah yeah okay thank you guys appreciate
you